as all but essential businesses remain
closed in New Yorkers stay home there
are signs that strict social distancing
measures are working the governor says
the state is seeing fewer
hospitalizations for the coronavirus we
can control the spread feel good about
that the worst is over yeah if we
continue to be smart going forward but
even as president Trump expresses his
hope to get Americans back to work in
May the governor warned against lifting
restrictions too soon New York's
governor said he'll be listening to
experts in public health and the economy
not politicians as to when it will be
safe for New Yorkers like me to leave
home and return to work but he'll do so
in consideration with governors from
neighboring states that includes when to
reopen schools the mayor of New York
City thinks they should stay closed
through June but I need to do to protect
kids and parents and families and
educators there's not going to be a
context to reopen schools with so much
we're gonna have to deal with on the
health front to get to a better place in
a more stable place but the governor
says ultimately that will be his
decision one he has yet to make Kristen
salumi al Jazeera New York